Hosting provided by Host Tornado. They offer website hosting packages, dedicated servers, and VPS solutions. HostT.net. Programming Throwdown, episode number 12, Dart. Take it away, Jason. Hey, guys. So we had a little bit of a hiatus. I was kind of doing a whole lot of traveling,
本节目由 Host Tornado 提供。他们提供网站托管套餐、专用服务器和 VPS 解决方案。HostT.net。Programming Throwdown，第 12 期，Dart。Jason，开始吧。嘿，伙计们。我们之前停播了一小段时间。我一直在到处旅行，
wasn't in my residency very frequently, and Patrick is a new father. Oh, no. Congratulations. Who decided that was acceptable? People did not get a vote on that, I promise you. He didn't get upvoted no oh dear um but yeah so it it uh babies have sort of been uh like a recurring thing you know like it's like one person
没怎么待在我的住院实习地，而且 Patrick 当爸爸了。哦，不。恭喜。谁觉得这可以接受？我保证，大家可没投票表决过这件事。他没被投票通过，哦，天哪，嗯，是的，所以，呃，生孩子这件事，你知道，就像是一种循环，就像是一个人
has a baby and a lot of our friends are having like my wife and a lot of our mutual friends are having babies now and so made me think about kids and one of the things that i think a lot about kids is i think about the you know how they relate to the internet and to tech and things like that you should think about diapers yeah well i just many diapers i told you know lindsey that like we could just adopt a 12 year old and get to like the cool part you know where they're into tech and computers have you met many 12 yearyear-olds? No. Okay. Yeah, maybe that's not such a good idea. But, yeah. So, you know, I was thinking, like, when we were kids, we, you know, our parents, well, maybe your parents were more savvy than mine, but my parents didn't understand anything about computers or the Internet.
生了孩子，我们很多朋友，比如我妻子和我们很多共同的朋友现在都在生孩子，这让我开始思考孩子的问题。关于孩子，我思考很多的一点是，我思考他们与互联网、科技以及类似事物的关系。你应该考虑一下尿布。是的，好吧，我只是……我知道很多尿布。我告诉 Lindsay，我们可以直接领养一个 12 岁的孩子，直接跳到酷的部分，你知道，就是他们对科技和电脑感兴趣的时候。你见过很多 12 岁的孩子吗？没有。好吧。是的，也许这不是个好主意。但是，是的。所以，你知道，我在想，当我们还是孩子的时候，我们的父母，嗯，也许你的父母比我的更精明，但我的父母对电脑或互联网一窍不通。
You know, my dad, he thought the computer was like an extension of the sewing machine, you know, using the his foot and everything it didn't make any sense that is awesome so we sort of had complete freedom on the internet like and you know you could argue that maybe it made us more responsible maybe it made us like more like adventurous you know it was really the internet was kind of like the wild wild west and we could you know have access to anything um and now you know the internet's become so big and there's there's there's so much content on there and also there's it's so uh more accessible that you have to wonder like for kids who are growing up nowadays like should you censor their internet um or should you sort of give them the same free reign we had yeah it is interesting we actually had some friends of ours who have a one-year-old over,
你知道，我爸爸，他以为电脑就像缝纫机的延伸，你知道，用他的脚操作什么的，这完全说不通。那太棒了。所以我们在互联网上拥有完全的自由，你可以说这也许让我们更有责任感，也许让我们更具冒险精神。你知道，互联网确实就像是狂野的西部，我们可以接触到任何东西。嗯，现在互联网变得如此庞大，上面的内容太多了，而且它也变得更容易访问，所以你不得不怀疑，对于现在长大的孩子来说，你应该审查他们的互联网吗？还是应该给他们我们曾经拥有的那种自由？是的，这很有趣。我们实际上有朋友带着一个一岁的孩子过来，
and the one-year-old was able to get on the phone and bring up YouTube and find Sesame Street videos and watch them on YouTube. And I looked at the parents and said, you realize there's other stuff on YouTube as well, right? And I guess that's only a relatively dangerous place to go on the Internet. But, I mean, yeah, it is an interesting question. So a lot of people do try to install these nanny software or filter software and block certain sites.
那个一岁大的孩子竟然能拿起手机，打开 YouTube，找到《芝麻街》的视频并在 YouTube 上观看。我看着那对父母说，你们意识到 YouTube 上还有其他东西，对吧？我想那只是互联网上一个相对危险的地方。但是，我的意思是，是的，这是一个有趣的问题。所以很多人确实尝试安装这些保姆软件或过滤软件，并屏蔽某些网站。
And the issue I have with those is that they don't really work. And then when the kids get older and if they haven't learned what's acceptable and what's not, they just figure out ways around it. And so it's not particularly effective. What I think is effective, I think, is educating yourself. educating yourself so we have an advantage of you know we already kind of know about computers so we understand these things and you know tell your kid
我对此的问题是，它们并不真正起作用。而且当孩子们长大后，如果他们没有学会什么是可以接受的，什么是不可以接受的，他们只会想出绕过这些限制的方法。所以这并不是特别有效。我认为有效的方法是自我教育。自我教育，所以我们有优势，你知道，我们已经了解电脑了，所以我们理解这些事情，而且，你知道，告诉你的孩子，
that look you know I need to be able to have access to your accounts now you don't ever use that and you hopefully you never have to but you need to share with them that like look this is important I need to be able to know what you're doing and it's for their safety just like you wouldn't allow them to go with people you didn't know to the park or whatever and i think it's important for them to trust you to not constantly be reading everything but they need to know that you can if they if something happens and that they need to know that that's the kind of thing that they need to be thinking about so i think that's one way and another way is also to have the computer in an area or have the usage pattern
你看，我需要能够访问你的账户。现在你永远不要使用它，希望你永远不必使用，但你需要与他们分享，你看，这很重要，我需要能够知道你在做什么，这是为了他们的安全。就像你不会允许他们和你不认识的人去公园一样。我认为让他们信任你，不要总是阅读他们的一切，这很重要，但他们需要知道，如果发生了什么事，你可以查看。他们需要知道这是他们需要考虑的事情。所以我认为这是一种方法。另一种方法是把电脑放在一个区域，或者设定使用模式，
set up such that as especially when they're area or have the usage pattern set up such that as especially when they're really young that the usage is very very limited right so that you only use a computer when they're there with you you know that kind of start sorry they only use a computer when you're there with them other way around like yeah okay bring your daughter to work every day oh no no that'd be hard but uh you know so that you're watching them and helping teach them good habits you know just like the state requires you to have a parent or some adult who's hopefully responsible around when you're learning to drive. You know, same kind of thing. As they're learning, they need to have somebody responsible around so they can learn good habits and, you know, what's the right way to do things.
设定好，特别是当他们还很小的时候，使用是非常非常有限的，对吧？所以只有当你在他们身边时，他们才使用电脑。你知道，那种开始……抱歉，他们只有在你和他们在一起时才使用电脑。反过来也一样，就像，好吧，每天带你女儿去上班。哦，不，不，那太难了。但你知道，这样你就可以看着他们，帮助教导他们养成良好的习惯。就像州政府要求你在学习开车时，身边必须有一位家长或某个希望是负责任的成年人一样。你知道，是一样的道理。当他们学习时，他们需要有负责任的人在身边，这样他们才能学习良好的习惯，以及，你知道，做事情的正确方式。
And then even as they continue to grow up and gain independence, still to have it somewhere where they know somebody will, you know, be around and pay attention to what they're doing and that you know show an interest in in caring about what they post online and you know sharing with them the danger about i think it's even different than when we were growing up because when we were growing up it's still mostly consumer oriented so you would go on the internet and consume things you know you would read things you would you know go to stuff that was a concern is you would view something that was damaging to you or that your parents didn't want you to view versus the relatively controlled media of like tv or cds or dvds or whatever that they would kind of know about um but i think the the extra danger that faces children today that is newer is this ability for phones and computers and everything to take video and then post that online or pictures as well. And I see that a lot.
即使在他们继续成长并获得独立时，仍然要把电脑放在他们知道有人会关注他们所做事情的地方。你知道，表现出对他们在线发布的内容的关心，并与他们分享危险。我认为这甚至与我们成长时不同，因为当我们成长时，它主要还是以消费为导向的。所以你会上网去消费东西，你会阅读东西，你会去浏览一些东西。令人担忧的是，你会查看一些对你有害的，或者你父母不希望你查看的东西，而不是像电视、CD 或 DVD 那样相对受控的媒体，他们多少会知道一些。但我认为今天孩子们面临的额外危险，是更新的，那就是手机、电脑和所有设备拍摄视频，然后将其发布到网上，或者发布照片的能力。我经常看到这种情况。
That's very dangerous because then the problem isn't you get damaged, you know, and then nobody kind of knows about it except you and maybe your parents or whatever, but that you could actually post something that's damaging to you and your family, you know, for everybody to see. And then the way the Internet works, that's really hard to remove references to that, you know. Yeah, definitely. If it's even possible. And so I think that is a far
这非常危险，因为问题不在于你受到了伤害，而且除了你和你父母之外，没人知道这件事，而在于你实际上可能发布了一些对自己和家人有害的东西，让所有人都能看到。而且互联网的运作方式，很难删除这些记录，你知道。是的，绝对是。如果这甚至可能的话。所以我认为那是一个远
more dangerous thing is people having youtube accounts where they allow children to upload to youtube or you know even having a facebook account reading other people's facebook statuses can be damaging enough but allowing your children to post pictures and stuff to facebook for others to view that's i mean how that's a very hard thing to control i would struggle with not what i allow my kids to watch or view or read but what i allow them to post yeah that's a good point i mean i think you're totally right on the nanny software i have a corker who's in sort of this arms race with his kids where you know he uh he blocks youtube and then they had some other website which is basically a mirror of youtube um and they just use that to get around it
更危险的事情。人们拥有 YouTube 账户，允许孩子上传到 YouTube，或者甚至拥有 Facebook 账户，阅读别人的 Facebook 状态可能已经足够有害了，但允许你的孩子在 Facebook 上发布照片等供他人查看，我的意思是，这很难控制。我会纠结的不是我允许我的孩子看什么、浏览什么或读什么，而是我允许他们发布什么。是的，这是一个很好的观点。我的意思是，我认为你在保姆软件上的看法完全正确。我有一个同事，他和他的孩子们处于这种军备竞赛中，他屏蔽了 YouTube，然后他们又找到了另一个网站，基本上是 YouTube 的镜像，他们就用那个来绕过它。
and then he blocks that and they have this whole back and forth and it really doesn't get the message across which is that you want ultimately what you want is for your kids to be responsible and you know setting up setting up a block and getting your kids to like spend a lot of their time figuring out how to break the system like i don't know might make your kid a great white hat hacker or something like that but it's not really getting the message but i think that that you're totally right that you should try to you know in the beginning walk your kids through the internet and sort of you know hold their hand you know as they get through it and then uh later on sort of i always feel like maybe what i would do is kind of spot check you know like if if if things are
然后他屏蔽了那个，他们就这样来回折腾，这真的没有传达出信息，那就是你最终想要的是让你的孩子有责任感。你知道，设置一个屏蔽，让你的孩子花大量时间去想办法破解系统，我不知道，可能会让你的孩子成为一个伟大的白帽黑客什么的，但这并没有真正传达出信息。但我认为你完全正确，你应该尝试，你知道，在开始时引导你的孩子使用互联网，并在他们通过时牵着他们的手。然后，呃，后来，我总觉得也许我会做的是进行抽查，你知道，如果事情
going okay and if if i there hasn't been anything weird or if i jump into my kids emails and you know they're uh there's nothing like weird or anything like that then uh you just give them the freedom to do whatever they want but then if they start getting into things which could be damaging because ultimately you're responsible i mean if they are part of some group that you know that hacks into i don't know some kind of like power plant or something like that like as a parent you'll be responsible for that and i think it's a judge when you're checking to say is this something minor or is this something major you know because it's something
进展顺利，如果我没有发现任何奇怪的事情，或者如果我查看我孩子的电子邮件，没有发现任何奇怪的东西，那么你就给他们自由去做他们想做的事。但如果他们开始接触可能有害的事情，因为最终你要负责。我的意思是，如果他们参与了某个黑客组织，黑进了某个发电厂之类的，作为家长，你要为此负责。我认为当你检查时，要判断这是否是小事还是大事，因为如果是小事，
minor you know and it's like it's like the kid who's playing a little rough and you know your parents were like fuss when you and your siblings were playing like hey somebody's gonna get hurt somebody's getting hurt they didn't always stop you then somebody would get hurt and they were right and you learned your lesson you know and that's kind of the way it worked versus if you're doing like you know juggling torches you know they probably would have stopped you like hey don't juggle torches you're gonna you know massively burn yourself so i mean i think that's the thing too is like noticing them doing something that's a little bad versus like something that could cause you know major harm yep yeah definitely it's got to be a case
你知道，就像孩子玩得有点粗鲁，当你和你的兄弟姐妹玩耍时，父母会大惊小怪，说“嘿，有人会受伤的，有人要受伤了”。他们并不总是阻止你，然后有人会受伤，他们是对的，你吸取了教训。你知道，这就是它的运作方式。相比之下，如果你在玩杂耍火把，他们可能会阻止你，说“嘿，别玩火把，你会严重烧伤自己的”。所以我的意思是，我认为这也是关键，就是注意到他们做了一些有点坏的事情，而不是那些可能导致重大伤害的事情。是的，绝对是。这必须是具体情况具体分析。
by case basis so i know growing up i uh was pretty responsible on the internet like pretty well responsible but so my parents kind of let me have free reign even you know as technology grew and understood more about the internet they never really had a problem with that but then like conversely it's really bad about doing chores especially like leaving the laundry i'd leave the laundry in the washing machine like just just sitting like wet laundry in the washing machine for like a day. And then those clothes are like virtually ruined. Like you have to rewash them. First, you have to like let them air dry.
所以我知道我成长过程中在互联网上还是挺负责任的，相当负责任。所以我的父母让我拥有自由，即使随着技术的发展，他们对互联网了解更多，他们也从未对此有过问题。但相反，我在做家务方面真的很糟糕，特别是洗衣服，我会把湿衣服留在洗衣机里，放上一整天。然后那些衣服几乎就毁了。你必须重新洗。首先，你必须让它们风干。
Then you have to rewash them. And so my parents are always on top of me like, do you check the laundry? All of our listeners are very excited about this. They did not know they were going to tune in and learn about the proper way to fix forgotten laundry in the washer. It's kind of the same way with your kids, right? Like if they, you know, this is just another dimension upon which you have to like sort of monitor your kids' behavior and stuff like that. I agree. And I think it's as hard as it is. I guess it's difficult for me. I don't really relate.
然后你必须重新洗。所以我的父母总是盯着我，问“你检查洗衣机了吗？”我们所有的听众都对这个很兴奋。他们不知道他们会收听并学习如何处理洗衣机里被遗忘的衣服。这和你的孩子是一样的，对吧？如果他们，你知道，这只是你需要监控孩子行为的另一个维度。我同意。而且我认为这很难。我想对我来说这很困难。我真的没有共鸣。
But people who are parents who aren't, i guess they're not listening to our post but parents for those parents who we all know who aren't as technical savvy i mean i think as technical people you have to help give good advice to those parents because they really don't know and there's a lot of people who really don't know anything about computers and you know you kind of got to give good advice to those people and help them to know what the right thing yeah definitely all right well news yeah yeah it's been a while but we'll try to keep news to relatively new news so so there's this thing you keep seeing around the internet at first i thought it was a dessert raspberry pie and i realized pie was spelled like the greek letter and it turns out it's a embedded computer device that looks pretty cool
但那些是父母的人，如果他们不是，我想他们不会听我们的节目。但对于那些我们都知道的、技术不太精通的父母，我的意思是，我认为作为技术人员，你必须帮助给那些父母提供好的建议，因为他们真的不知道。有很多人对电脑一窍不通，你知道，你得给这些人提供好的建议，帮助他们知道什么是正确的。是的，绝对是。好吧，新闻。是的，是的，已经有一段时间了，但我们会尽量保持新闻相对较新。所以，网上一直有这个东西，起初我以为是甜点 Raspberry Pie（树莓派），后来我意识到 Pie 的拼写和希腊字母一样，结果发现它是一个嵌入式计算机设备，看起来很酷。
um a group of people got together and said you know that they want to make a embedded computer that's going to be $35 that runs Linux and see what people do with it similar to we talked about on the show before the Arduino and other such devices and uh I heard you had you had found this already independently right you had been been looking at these and you even have your name on the wait list. Yeah, yeah, definitely. I'm on the wait list to grab a Raspberry Pi. It's relatively small. It's embedded.
嗯，一群人聚在一起说，他们想制造一个 35 美元的嵌入式计算机，运行 Linux，看看人们用它做什么。类似于我们之前在节目中谈到的 Arduino 和其他此类设备。而且我听说你已经独立发现了这个，对吧？你一直在关注这些，甚至你的名字还在等待名单上。是的，是的，绝对是。我在等待名单上，想弄到一个树莓派。它相对较小。它是嵌入式的。
So for people who aren't too familiar with embedded device, basically what that means is it's an entire computer on a single wafer. So on a single like sheet. Yeah, single board. So I'm trying to pull up the specs on how big it is. I think it's like about twice the size of a credit card. So like two credit cards, you can imagine like squarish, like stacked square wise. And so it has many different things on it. So it has, you know, obviously a processor. It has an SD card. So you can pop an SD card, even a 32-gig SD card for storage.
所以对于那些不太熟悉嵌入式设备的人来说，基本上这意味着它是一整台计算机，在一块晶圆上。所以在一张像纸一样的板子上。是的，单板。所以我正在尝试调出它的规格，看看它有多大。我想它大约是信用卡大小的两倍。所以就像两张信用卡，你可以想象成方形的，像堆叠起来的方形。所以它上面有很多不同的东西。它显然有一个处理器。它有一个 SD 卡。所以你可以插入一张 SD 卡，甚至是一张 32GB 的 SD 卡用于存储。
There's a $35, which is $10 more than the base $25 model. That has an Ethernet port on it. But other than that, it still has USB, has HDMI out. I think it even has RCA out and stereo out. So you can imagine you're plugging one of these into your television. You could, it has a GPIO. For people who aren't familiar with that, that's basically a way to. General purpose input and output?
有一个 35 美元的版本，比基础的 25 美元型号贵 10 美元。它上面有一个以太网端口。但除此之外，它仍然有 USB，有 HDMI 输出。我想它甚至有 RCA 输出和立体声输出。所以你可以想象你把其中一个插入你的电视。它有一个 GPIO。对于不熟悉这个的人来说，这基本上是一种……通用输入输出？
Yep, that's right. It's basically a way to talk to different things. If you have, excuse me, if you have little motors, so you want to make, say, a robot car or something like that, you could totally use a GPIO interface to talk to those stepper motors or talk to those brushless motors if you're making an airplane or whatever. So you can do all sorts of really fun stuff with it. Do you have any ideas of what you would do if you got one? There's so many cool things. Actually, with the baby, you start thinking of, you see stuff in the you see stuff in the store like i can make something that does the same thing or you
是的，没错。这基本上是一种与不同事物对话的方式。如果你有，抱歉，如果你有小电机，你想制造，比如说，一个机器人车之类的，你完全可以使用 GPIO 接口与那些步进电机对话，或者如果你在制造飞机什么的，与那些无刷电机对话。所以你可以用它做各种非常有趣的事情。如果你有一个，你有什么想法吗？有很多很酷的事情。实际上，有了孩子，你开始思考，你在商店里看到东西，就像我可以制造一个做同样事情的东西，或者你
know real feeding the baby takes a long time you know so like if you give the baby a bottle or whatever and they drink but it takes a long time they're not good at holding it themselves i think i really should design something to hold this so that you know i can go do other stuff and uh basically try to be as lazy as possible um but yeah so constantly i'm thinking of things like that but uh i think that having hdmi is really useful that's something that is traditionally basically try to be as lazy as possible. But yeah, so constantly I'm thinking of things like that, but I think that having HDMI is really useful. That's something that is traditionally very and also RCA video, but just having
知道，喂孩子需要很长时间，你知道，所以如果你给孩子一个奶瓶什么的，他们喝，但这需要很长时间，他们不擅长自己拿着它。我想我真的应该设计一个东西来拿着它，这样我就可以去做别的事情了，基本上尽量变得尽可能懒。嗯，是的，所以我一直在想这样的事情。但我认为拥有 HDMI 非常有用，这是传统上……基本上尽量变得尽可能懒。但是的，所以我一直在想这样的事情，但我认为拥有 HDMI 非常有用。这是传统上非常……而且还有 RCA 视频，但仅仅拥有
video output built in and so cheap has a lot of things because we've talked about before, it's very rewarding to program something and see it in video and pictures and that's why I think part of what game programming is such a thing that people get introduced to programming through. And this board being so cheap and having that video capability is very intriguing and what can you display onto a tv because everybody has tvs
内置的视频输出，而且如此便宜，有很多用途，因为我们之前谈过，编程并看到视频和图片是非常有成就感的，这就是为什么我认为游戏编程是人们接触编程的原因之一。这个板子如此便宜，并且具有视频功能，非常吸引人，你可以在电视上显示什么呢？因为每个人都有电视，
and it's understandable and your friends you know if you show a little motor that spins around it's like okay or oh look i blinked this led in morse code okay like that nobody cares but if you like put something up on the TV, then, like, people are like, wow, this is awesome. Like, how did you do this? So that's really intriguing to me. Yeah, definitely. I mean, personally, the first thing I'm going to do on it is get MAME,
而且这很容易理解。你的朋友，你知道，如果你展示一个小电机旋转，他们会说“好吧”，或者“哦，看，我用摩尔斯电码闪烁了这个 LED，好吧”，没人关心。但如果你把东西放到电视上，那么人们会说，“哇，这太棒了。你是怎么做到的？”所以这对我来说真的很吸引人。是的，绝对是。我的意思是，就我个人而言，我打算在上面做的第一件事是安装 MAME，
you know, Multiple Arcade Machine Emulator compiled on it. I have no idea why I want to do that. It already runs on my phone. So, like, can it run Doom? Everything else. It's not a proper computer until it runs Doom? Yeah, that's right. That's right. so i get a bunch of those stuff on it uh but i think long term what i'd really want to do with it is um either some kind of like social uh kind of like
你知道，Multiple Arcade Machine Emulator（多重街机模拟器），把它编译上去。我不知道为什么我想这样做。它已经在我的手机上运行了。所以，它能运行 Doom 吗？其他一切。如果它不能运行 Doom，它就不是一台像样的电脑？是的，没错。没错。所以我会在上面弄一堆东西。但我认为从长远来看，我真正想用它做的是，嗯，要么是某种社交，某种
communication thing so maybe a bunch of people at a party or something you could have this as like a centerpiece and talk to it from your phones or something like that that'd be cool yeah yeah there's definitely make a robot that can fit you drinks from the refrigerator or something like that so you and thousands of nerds before you have attempted such an endeavor will you be the first to completely succeed yeah it takes power i don't know if uh it doesn't have a battery per se but i'm sure people will add a module for that it also um it doesn't have any type of wi-fi like bluetooth or um you know or wireless but um it does have a usb port and already some people are mass producing like really tiny little wi-fi nubs that plug into the usb port and add a little
交流的东西，所以也许在聚会上，你可以把它作为中心，从你的手机上与它对话什么的，那会很酷。是的，是的，绝对可以制造一个可以为你从冰箱里拿饮料的机器人什么的。所以你和成千上万的极客在你之前都尝试过这样的努力，你会是第一个完全成功的人吗？是的，这需要电力。我不知道，它本身没有电池，但我肯定人们会为它添加一个模块。它也没有任何类型的 Wi-Fi，比如蓝牙，或者，你知道，无线。但它确实有一个 USB 端口，已经有人在批量生产像非常微小的 Wi-Fi 适配器，插入 USB 端口并增加一点
bit to the profile but in bluetooth ones as well similarly small that's right and i think they're looking at making a new version like a model c or something which will have wi-fi so look out for that in the future yeah it could be cool something to keep your eye on and uh the so the article that that brought this up for the news is not only is this cool but they've had issues again um we never really talked about it here but a lot of hardware manufacturers have this when you it's very difficult to actually build something, unlike software, which you just kind of release it, and it's still very hard to get rid of all the bugs.
轮廓，蓝牙的也一样，同样小。没错，而且我认为他们正在考虑制造一个新版本，比如 Model C 之类的，它会有 Wi-Fi，所以未来请留意这一点。是的，那会很酷，值得关注。而且，带来这个新闻的文章不仅说这很酷，而且他们又遇到了问题。嗯，我们在这里从未真正谈论过，但很多硬件制造商在制造东西时都会遇到这种情况，这与软件不同，软件你只是发布它，而且仍然很难消除所有的错误。
But with hardware, not only do you have the issue with the bugs, but sourcing the parts, getting the parts installed correctly, making sure you have the right parts. Somebody could send you a batch. I was reading the other day about somebody who was trying to make a hardware kit, and they got wrong LEDs, and it happened they were counterfeit LEDs. Oh, man. And it causes all sorts of implications. So they were going through they were counterfeit leds oh and you know causes all
但对于硬件，你不仅有错误的问题，还有采购零件、正确安装零件、确保你有正确的零件的问题。有人可能会给你发一批货。我前几天读到关于有人试图制造一个硬件套件，他们得到了错误的 LED，而且碰巧它们是假冒的 LED。哦，天哪。这会导致各种各样的影响。所以他们正在经历……它们是假冒的 LED，哦，你知道，导致各种
sorts of implications so they were going through some troubles with having wrong ethernet port parts so yeah i saw that they didn't have i guess proper shielding on the ethernet but supposedly it's been fixed now so so that's good news and i i honestly think that you know save yourself the ten dollars and buy the one that doesn't have ethernet and put a wi-fi yeah especially if you wait a little bit and see if which which wi-fi is the best supported one yeah that's right that wi-fi they're actually if you go to the faq there's a section on wi-fi and it has a list of like ones they recommend that that's a really important point um so i've done a lot of this kind of stuff before i've used gumsticks patrick's done a lot with arduino and you know a lot of this kind of stuff before I've used gum sticks Patrick's done a lot with Arduino and you know a lot of these embedded operating systems they don't support you know a wide range
影响。所以他们正在经历一些关于以太网端口零件错误的麻烦。所以是的，我看到他们没有，我想以太网没有适当的屏蔽，但据说是现在已经修复了。所以这是个好消息。而且我真心认为，你知道，省下那十美元，买那个没有以太网的，然后插上 Wi-Fi。是的，特别是如果你等一会儿，看看哪种 Wi-Fi 是支持最好的。是的，没错。那个 Wi-Fi，实际上如果你去常见问题解答，有一个关于 Wi-Fi 的部分，它有一个他们推荐的列表。这是一个非常重要的点。嗯，所以我之前做过很多这种事情，我用过 Gumstix，Patrick 用过很多 Arduino，你知道，我之前做过很多这种事情，我用过 Gumstix，Patrick 用过很多 Arduino，你知道，很多这种嵌入式操作系统，它们不支持，你知道，广泛的
of hardware so you might go to Best Buy let's say and buy USB Wi-Fi and it just won't work and it's because so much on the software level just hasn't been implemented for this OS. Well and often it's proprietary so whoever makes that particular stick D-Link or whatever won't release a Linux driver for it, or will release it in such a way that it's very hard to get that to work on other platforms or other devices. Yeah. So keep in mind that embedded devices run what's called ARM. Most of them run ARM. And long story short is ARM is just a different type of processor than what you have on your desktop. So the instructions are different. For example, like if you want to move data from one register to another, just a way to describe that action in ARM is different. And the set of instructions is different.
硬件。所以你可能会去百思买，比如说，买一个 USB Wi-Fi，它就是不能用，这是因为在软件层面，很多东西还没有为这个操作系统实现。嗯，而且通常它是专有的，所以无论谁制造那个特定的适配器，D-Link 或其他什么，都不会为它发布 Linux 驱动程序，或者会以一种非常难以在其他平台或其他设备上工作的方式发布它。是的。所以请记住，嵌入式设备运行的是所谓的 ARM。它们大多数运行 ARM。长话短说，ARM 是一种与你桌面上的处理器不同类型的处理器。所以指令是不同的。例如，如果你想把数据从一个寄存器移动到另一个寄存器，描述该动作的方式在 ARM 中是不同的。而且指令集也是不同的。
So because of that, even if you have some USB Wi-Fi adapter that works in Ubuntu, you know, on your desktop doesn't necessarily mean that it'll work on these embedded systems for that reason. And talk about confusing consumers. Yeah, so embedded systems require a little bit of, you know, thinking beforehand. But the nice thing, the whole goal of this Raspberry Pi is that up until now, even Arduino was close to $100, right? You can get ones that are fairly cheap, yeah. The thing is that they're not accomplishing the same kind of task, and they've been around for a lot longer. Gotcha, gotcha.
所以正因为如此，即使你有一个在 Ubuntu 上工作的 USB Wi-Fi 适配器，你知道，在你的桌面上，并不一定意味着它会在这些嵌入式系统上工作，就是因为这个原因。谈谈让消费者困惑。是的，所以嵌入式系统需要一点，你知道，事先思考。但好的一点是，这个树莓派的全部目标是，直到现在，即使是 Arduino 也接近 100 美元，对吧？你可以买到相当便宜的，是的。问题是它们没有完成同样类型的任务，而且它们已经存在很长时间了。明白了，明白了。
Yeah, because I know that Gumsticks, which has similar specs to this, was close to $600. So this being $35, it opens this technology up to a whole new audience. And so I think that people will be much more educated about embedded systems moving forward. Yeah, and it's definitely a useful skill. Talking about people interested in skills that transfer to the real world. I mean, there are many, many, many, many, many companies out there doing stuff with embedded computing platforms and systems. And learning how to program in a limited resource environment that the systems represent
是的，因为我知道 Gumstix，它的规格与此类似，接近 600 美元。所以这个 35 美元的价格，向全新的受众开放了这项技术。所以我认为人们在未来会更了解嵌入式系统。是的，这绝对是一项有用的技能。谈到人们对转移到现实世界的技能感兴趣。我的意思是，外面有非常非常非常非常多的公司在做嵌入式计算平台和系统方面的事情。学习如何在系统所代表的资源受限环境中进行编程
is a very transferable skill yeah definitely so talking about making a robot yeah so um we're going to talk now about uh california being the second state to allow autonomous cars so what was the first one so the first state was nevada okay, they passed the bill a few months ago. It wasn't that long ago. Up until then, people had been sort of testing autonomous cars in very controlled environments. Then Nevada passed a law not too long ago saying that as long as somebody is in the car, you can have a machine or have a computer driving the car. But there had to be a person there to sort of supervise and take control. Yeah, so I thought a lot about this. In addition to censorship for kids, no.
是一项非常可转移的技能。是的，绝对是。所以谈到制造机器人，是的。所以，我们现在要谈谈加利福尼亚州成为第二个允许自动驾驶汽车的州。那么第一个是什么？第一个州是内华达州。好吧，他们几个月前通过了法案。没过多久。在此之前，人们一直在非常受控的环境中测试自动驾驶汽车。然后内华达州不久前通过了一项法律，说只要有人在车里，你就可以让机器或电脑驾驶汽车。但必须有一个人在那里进行监督并接管控制。是的，所以我思考了很多关于这个的问题。除了对孩子的审查，不。
So I think about autonomous cars because I really want one. Every day when I commute to work, I think, I want that autonomous car. Where is it? When is it coming? The other week we drove to L.A., which is, we both don't know, the drive from Northern California to L.A. is about, what, six hours, seven hours, something like that. So it's a long drive. And the whole time I was thinking, God, if I had an autonomous car, like all four of the seats could just face the middle,
所以我思考自动驾驶汽车，因为我真的很想要一辆。每天我通勤上班时，我都在想，我想要那辆自动驾驶汽车。它在哪里？它什么时候来？上周我们开车去洛杉矶，我们俩都不知道，从北加州到洛杉矶的车程大约是，什么，六个小时，七个小时，类似那样。所以这是一段很长的车程。整个过程中我都在想，天哪，如果我有一辆自动驾驶汽车，所有四个座位都可以面向中间，
and we could be playing Agricola or Power Grid right now. Board games. Yeah, we could totally be board gaming for seven hours. This is time that is so valuable time yeah so so i think about this i just it's going to be one of those things that i think is going to even once the technology enables it it's still not going to be here and it's just going to be one of those things it's kind of because it's going to be so hard who do you blame when an accident happens you know the officer shows up and who does he write the ticket
我们现在就可以玩《Agricola》或《Power Grid》。棋盘游戏。是的，我们完全可以玩七个小时的棋盘游戏。这是非常有价值的时间。是的，所以我思考这个问题，我只是觉得这将是那种即使技术实现了，它仍然不会在这里的事情之一，而且它将是那种因为太难而无法实现的事情之一。当事故发生时，你责怪谁？你知道，警察来了，他给谁开罚单？
to you know who do the what do the insurance companies do you know how do they price that in to insure cars that are autonomous um you know all these situations or even uh the i know there was one case where an autonomous car was driving and got rear-ended well i don't think the autonomy was on at the time but even if it did like what happens if it's not even the fault of the autonomous car the first thing that's going to happen is despite how much does engineers it doesn't make sense the first time somebody rear ends a car that's autonomous and it was 100 their fault but they have a really good lawyer that lawyer is going to bring a lawsuit against the other person saying that they want all the source code for the autonomous car they want it reviewed they they think it's his fault that it applied the brakes too suddenly faster than what a human
你知道，保险公司怎么做？你知道，他们如何定价来为自动驾驶汽车投保？嗯，所有这些情况，或者甚至，我知道有一个案例，一辆自动驾驶汽车在行驶时被追尾了。嗯，我不认为当时自动驾驶功能开启了，但即使开启了，如果甚至不是自动驾驶汽车的错，会发生什么？第一件事就是，尽管工程师们怎么说，这说不通，第一次有人追尾一辆自动驾驶汽车，而且 100% 是他们的错，但他们有一个非常好的律师，那个律师会针对另一个人提起诉讼，说他们想要自动驾驶汽车的所有源代码，他们想要审查它，他们认为是因为它刹车太突然，比人类
could have or any of these things and basically in a fight to try to get overturned and then it's going to cause get caught up in a legal quagmire for the foreseeable future yeah the thing i'm worried about too is or just interested i guess more is the better word is are people going to be able to game the autonomous car so let's say half the cars on the road are autonomous and you need to get to work and you're really in a hurry like you're late for work if you turn off the autonomous mode can you like somehow game the ai that's driving the other cars if you flash your lights three times and you wibble your car it thinks you're drunk and so it gets out of the way yeah exactly you can just speed past it yeah so i think there's almost going to be an arms race between the people who have between the autonomous cars and the human drivers who want to get past them well i think early the you know like high occupancy
可能做的更快，或者任何这些事情，基本上是一场试图推翻的斗争，然后它会在可预见的未来陷入法律泥潭。是的，我担心的另一件事，或者只是感兴趣，我想更好的词是，人们是否能够玩弄自动驾驶汽车？所以假设路上有一半的汽车是自动驾驶的，你需要去上班，而且你真的很匆忙，比如你上班迟到了，如果你关闭自动驾驶模式，你能以某种方式玩弄驾驶其他汽车的 AI 吗？如果你闪烁三次灯，并且摇晃你的车，它认为你喝醉了，所以它会避开。是的，完全正确，你可以直接加速超过它。是的，所以我认为在拥有自动驾驶汽车的人和想要超过他们的人类驾驶员之间，几乎会有一场军备竞赛。嗯，我认为早期的，你知道，高占用率
lanes and stuff like this will be enabled for autonomous cars because they can drive so much closer and so they'll be able to say like this is an autonomous car and they'll have special designated lanes for them or show them so that it's different because that is going to be the most difficult time if we switch completely to an infrastructure that supported autonomous cars and there were only autonomous cars on the road it would be very simple actually or when you get onto a freeway it's required that you have autonomy enabled you're not able to you're not allowed to disable it while you're on the freeway it would be very easy yeah but definitely between now and then
车道之类的东西将为自动驾驶汽车启用，因为它们可以开得更近，所以他们将能够说，这是一辆自动驾驶汽车，他们会有专门指定的车道给它们，或者展示它们，这样它就不同了，因为如果我们将基础设施完全切换到支持自动驾驶汽车，并且路上只有自动驾驶汽车，那将是最困难的时期，实际上会非常简单。或者当你进入高速公路时，要求你启用自动驾驶，你在高速公路上时不允许禁用它，那会非常容易。是的，但绝对是在那之前
what do you do like you're gonna have in the beginning you know very few cars which autonomous then slowly more and more and more and through each of these phases autonomous cars have to behave differently yep yeah definitely i just i think that you know in some senses though i think that um i just wonder if people will be more or less stressed because the you know, they'll be stressed because they could go faster if they were driving it themselves. Part of the whole thing about the autonomous car is that it'll probably do close to the speed limit. I mean, I'm sure the autonomous. Well, but that speed limit in theory will go up because it doesn't even make sense anymore.
你做什么？比如在开始时，你知道，很少有汽车是自动驾驶的，然后慢慢地越来越多，通过每一个阶段，自动驾驶汽车必须表现得不同。是的，绝对是。我只是觉得，在某种意义上，我只是想知道人们是否会感到压力更大或更小，因为你知道，他们会感到压力，因为如果他们自己驾驶，他们可以开得更快。关于自动驾驶汽车的整个事情是，它可能会以接近限速的速度行驶。我的意思是，我肯定自动驾驶。嗯，但那个限速理论上会提高，因为它甚至不再有意义了。
Yeah. Because the car will just know what the safest speed it can drive at based on everything. I wonder if you if you'll be able to customize it i wonder if there'll be autonomous car hackers yeah so i mean in the state of california for those of you don't know they actually have a thing so if you want to get your car basically you know registered to drive they inspect it and they look for you know modifications that aren't approved that make it emit too much pollution they test it to see how much pollution it emits all these kind of things there will be a check you know checksum on your you know autonomous software and if the checksum for your software doesn't check out they know you modified it and they're going to you know write you a ticket
是的。因为汽车会根据一切知道它能行驶的最安全速度。我想知道你是否能够自定义它，我想知道是否会有自动驾驶汽车黑客。是的，我的意思是，在加利福尼亚州，对于那些不知道的人，他们实际上有一件事，所以如果你想让你的车基本上，你知道，注册驾驶，他们会检查它，他们会寻找，你知道，未批准的修改，导致它排放过多的污染，他们测试它看看它排放多少污染，所有这些事情。你的自动驾驶软件上会有校验和，如果你的软件校验和对不上，他们就知道你修改了它，他们会，你知道，给你开罚单。
yep so something like that so uh you know also i recommend you get yourself on the raspberry pi waiting list as i'm on so that you can write your autonomous car hacker when both of these things are made available and if you want to learn how to write an autonomous car, I have another news link for you. Stanford is just starting to roll out some new online courses. So last semester, quarter, I guess last year at some point, Stanford did the first of these, which was machine learning. And I think they had another one as well.
是的，所以类似的事情。所以，你知道，我也建议你把自己加入到树莓派的等待名单上，就像我一样，这样当这两样东西都可用时，你就可以编写你的自动驾驶汽车黑客程序。如果你想学习如何编写自动驾驶汽车，我还有另一个新闻链接给你。斯坦福大学刚刚开始推出一些新的在线课程。所以上个学期，季度，我想去年某个时候，斯坦福大学做了这些课程中的第一个，也就是机器学习。我想他们还有另一个。
And it's by a really reputable, I'm going to mess the name Andrew Ning. Andrew Ng. Okay yeah there's like a I guess a hidden eye not a silent eye but the opposite there's a hidden eye. So it's Andrew Ng and he is a professor at Stanford and he taught this machine learning class to the internet for free and it's structured very much like a class um that you would take out of college, you know, with exams and everything. But it's all automated and tests and a schedule for you to go through and forums for you to talk on. And you get a certificate upon completion. Oh, okay. So I started in it and then I got busy and didn't end up finishing it.
而且它是由一个非常有声望的，我要把名字弄乱了，Andrew Ning。Andrew Ng。好的，是的，有一个，我想是一个隐藏的 i，不是一个沉默的 i，而是相反，有一个隐藏的 i。所以是 Andrew Ng，他是斯坦福大学的教授，他免费向互联网教授这门机器学习课程，它的结构非常像你在大学里上的课程，你知道，有考试和一切。但它是完全自动化的，有测试，有让你完成的时间表，还有供你交流的论坛。完成课程后你会获得证书。哦，好的。所以我开始了，然后我忙起来了，最后没能完成。
And so I actually thought about having it. But this year they're rolling out a lot more of those courses. So I'm here on the list and some of them include the machine learning one again, software as a service. This is a buzzword starting to lose some of its shine, but still important. Natural language processing.
所以我实际上考虑过拥有它。但今年他们推出了更多这样的课程。所以我在这里的名单上，其中一些包括再次机器学习，软件即服务。这是一个开始失去光泽的流行语，但仍然很重要。自然语言处理。
So getting computers to work with, you know, spoken and the written word. Cryptography, design and analysis of algorithms, computer vision. I mean, these are the kinds of things nerds really like. I mean, sorry, we really like. And then they have a few
所以让计算机与，你知道，口语和书面语一起工作。密码学，算法的设计与分析，计算机视觉。我的意思是，这些是极客们真正喜欢的东西。我的意思是，抱歉，我们真的很喜欢。然后他们还有几个
more which are getting ready to come out that you know are going to be out this year probabilistic graphical models so this is how xbox's true skill works on a system some of this game theory human computer interaction computer science 101 maybe we should have all the parents who allow their kids on the internet to take computer science 101. No, okay, that's a bad idea. Information theory and anatomy. Really? Anatomy? Anatomy. I don't think it's anatomy of a computer.
准备出来的，你知道今年会出来的，概率图模型，所以这就是 Xbox 的 True Skill 在系统上的工作方式，一些博弈论，人机交互，计算机科学 101。也许我们应该让所有允许孩子上网的父母都去上计算机科学 101。不，好的，那是个坏主意。信息论和解剖学。真的？解剖学？解剖学。我不认为它是计算机的解剖学。
I was going to say, is it like von Neumann anatomy? No, no, no. Computer security and making green buildings. Really? So they're starting to branch out, but most of these are still applicable to computer people. And so I would recommend if you are not a person who's enrolled in college or graduated with a computer science degree or not already a programmer and you want to start learning some of those things and getting involved, this is an excellent,
我正想说，它是像冯·诺依曼解剖学吗？不，不，不。计算机安全和制造绿色建筑。真的？所以他们开始涉足其他领域，但其中大多数仍然适用于计算机人员。所以我建议，如果你不是一个在大学注册或拥有计算机科学学位的人，或者不是一个已经是程序员的人，并且你想开始学习其中一些东西并参与进来，这是一个极好的，
completely free resource for you to use. And I think, so we've had discussions about this at work about, you know, having a child and what is the university system going to be like when our children you know become college age will colleges as they stand today exist will it be completely online will it be a hybrid what will happen it's getting so expensive to go to college now yeah i don't think it's sustainable that something is going to change something will break and what's it going to be like and what does that mean for putting away money? So it's so big today, because college is so expensive for parents to put away money for their kids to go to college. And if college is going to be completely different in, you know, 18 years, what does that mean? How do you plan for that? What should you
完全免费的资源供您使用。我想，我们在工作中讨论过这个问题，比如，生孩子，当我们的孩子到了上大学的年龄时，大学体系会是什么样子？现在的大学还会存在吗？会完全在线吗？还是混合模式？会发生什么？现在上大学变得太贵了，是的，我不认为这是可持续的，有些事情将会改变，有些事情将会崩溃，那会是什么样子？这对存钱意味着什么？所以今天这个问题很大，因为对于父母来说，为孩子存钱上大学太昂贵了。如果 18 年后大学完全不同了，那意味着什么？你该如何为此做计划？你应该
teach your children now about learning online so that they can be prepared to be in classrooms where there's no physical teacher? Yeah, definitely. I mean, I know it took several of my courses on, I think UCF called it feeds, but I'm sure there's something similar at UF where you take the course online and there's essentially a camera set up in the classroom and things like that. But then you showed up for the exams. So that was starting to approach, you know, totally online. But now I know several courses at many universities are done completely online there's a different skill set though because there's no when you have class there's some even if you go depending on your college and what class and your major and your professor's uh niceness or not you know there's some amount of peer pressure and obligation to
现在教你的孩子关于在线学习的什么，以便他们能准备好在没有实体老师的教室里学习？是的，绝对是。我的意思是，我知道我参加了几个课程，我想 UCF 称之为 feeds，但我相信 UF 也有类似的东西，你在线上课，教室里基本上架设了一台摄像机之类的东西。但你还是要到场参加考试。所以这开始接近完全在线了。但现在我知道许多大学的许多课程都是完全在线完成的，不过这需要一套不同的技能，因为当你上课时，即使你去上课，取决于你的大学、课程、专业以及教授的友善程度，你知道，会有一定程度的同伴压力和义务去
show up to class and listen to them talk when they're talking and that keeps you on schedule if it's on video you can always just watch it tomorrow yeah but if you keep just i'm gonna watch it tomorrow you never watch it and then what happens when you have to show up and take the test and you know there's a level of self-motivation that you have to enforce on yourself there yeah definitely our online courses at university i remember even though they were online and the videos were available people still would go watch the recording of the video go watch the teacher be recorded doing it because that was the only way they could make sure that they would learn the material and do well on the test yeah definitely i can say with the from experience that the machine learning course is awesome i mean i took
去上课，在他们说话时听他们讲，这能让你保持进度。如果是视频，你总是可以明天再看，是的，但如果你一直说“我明天再看”，你就永远不会看，然后当你必须去参加考试时会发生什么？你知道，你必须对自己施加一定程度的自我激励。是的，绝对是。我记得我们在大学的在线课程，即使它们是在线且有视频，人们仍然会去观看视频录像，去观看老师被录制下来的讲课过程，因为那是他们确保能学会材料并在考试中取得好成绩的唯一方法。是的，绝对是。我可以凭经验说，机器学习课程非常棒，我的意思是，我参加了
it kind of as a refresher um with uh some of my co-workers and and it was extremely useful. And the cool thing especially about this particular course is that it covers a lot of, like, applied machine learning. So, you know, the guy doesn't go into a whole lot of theory. I mean, there's some of it, you know, what you'd expect from an academic course, but it's a lot of sort of hands-on, very specific examples. And they actually talk about how to do like image search for example is one of the things they cover in the course and so uh they do like i think they do google news so andrew ing actually works for google and so uh he brings up a lot of
它，算是复习，和一些同事一起，它非常有用。特别酷的一点是，这门特定的课程涵盖了很多应用机器学习的内容。所以，你知道，那个人并没有深入探讨太多的理论。我的意思是，有一些，你知道，你会从学术课程中期待的那样，但它有很多实践性的、非常具体的例子。他们实际上谈到了如何做图像搜索，例如，这是他们在课程中涵盖的内容之一，所以他们做了，我想他们做了谷歌新闻，所以吴恩达实际上为谷歌工作，所以他提出了很多
examples from things that he's done in his career so if you ever wonder how some of those things work on you know behind the scenes you can can take this course and get it straight from the horse's mouth. That almost should have been our tool of the week, sort of. That's an awesome recommendation for people. Yeah, it's a killer tool. It's almost too good to be a tool of the week. One day we'll tell our kids, I remember when. Yeah, back in my day.
他职业生涯中做过的事情的例子，所以如果你曾经想知道其中一些事情在幕后是如何运作的，你可以参加这门课程，直接从源头了解。这几乎应该成为我们的本周工具，某种程度上。这对人们来说是一个很棒的推荐。是的，这是一个杀手级工具。它好到几乎不能作为本周工具。总有一天我们会告诉我们的孩子，我记得那时候。是的，在我的那个年代。
Back in my day, the first course came out. That'll be interesting. So speaking of tools, do you have, oh, wait, tools of the bi-week. Although it's not really been bi-week any longer. I can't really say that. It's a tool of the bi-month. Tool of the semi-halfway through the year. So what is your tool recommendation for this this recording? Yeah, so this is this is a problem that almost everybody has, you know, is a disk space.
在我的那个年代，第一门课程出来了。那会很有趣。说到工具，你有，哦，等等，双周工具。虽然它已经不再是双周了。我不能真的那样说。这是双月工具。半年工具。那么你这次录音的工具推荐是什么？是的，所以这是一个几乎每个人都有的问题，你知道，就是磁盘空间。
Right. When I bought whenever I buy a computer, I always buy the lowest processor to let me buy in the lowest memory. And it's just it just doesn't seem to make sense ever to spend twice as much for a better processor when you know it's going to be out of date. But I always buy the most hard drive space I can, especially with a laptop. But even with desktops, I fill it full of hard disks, and I always invariably seem to run out of space. So that's interesting because I actually do the opposite. So I tend to be more willing to spend for a processor or RAM, things which are, in my opinion, more difficult to replace on a laptop or even on a desktop of some sort.
对。当我买电脑时，我总是买我能买到的最低处理器和最低内存。花两倍的钱买更好的处理器似乎从来没有意义，因为你知道它很快就会过时。但我总是买我能买到的最大的硬盘空间，尤其是笔记本电脑。但即使是台式机，我也把它装满硬盘，而且我总是不可避免地用完空间。这很有趣，因为我实际上做了相反的事情。所以我倾向于更愿意花钱买处理器或内存，在我看来，这些在笔记本电脑甚至台式机上更难更换。
And then buy a smallest hard drive, knowing that I'll fill it up and replace it no matter what size I put in. And then as soon as I fill it up, I can just go buy it online much cheaper than their upgrade price. I can buy a new hard drive to plug it in and take the old hard drive and make it external. That works for desktops, right? No, it works for laptops as well.
然后买一个最小的硬盘，因为我知道无论我装多大的，我都会把它填满并更换它。一旦我填满了，我就可以在网上以比他们的升级价格便宜得多的价格买到它。我可以买一个新的硬盘插进去，把旧的硬盘拿出来做成外置硬盘。这对台式机有效，对吧？不，这对笔记本电脑也有效。
Really? Yeah. Wait, how do you swap the hard drive on? Oh, I guess maybe, I don't think you can swap the hard drive on this, can you? Oh, on a MacBook? Oh, I don't know. You have to look online. I'm sure there's a way.
真的吗？是的。等等，你怎么更换硬盘？哦，我想也许，我不认为你可以在这个上面更换硬盘，对吧？哦，在 MacBook 上？哦，我不知道。你必须在网上查一下。我相信一定有办法。
Yeah, there's probably some way. But most computers, it's fairly straightforward to swap the hard drive. Yeah, yeah. But continue, sorry. I still fill the hard drives up no matter what. Even more quickly because I buy the cheap one. Yeah, so basically these are a set of three tools, depending on which OS you use, Windows, Linux, or OS X, which will tell you in each directory what disks you're using. And more specifically what it does, it gives you these really cool visualizations.
是的，可能有什么办法。但大多数电脑，更换硬盘是相当直接的。是的，是的。但继续，抱歉。无论如何，我还是会把硬盘填满。甚至更快，因为我买的是便宜的。是的，所以基本上这是一套三个工具，取决于你使用什么操作系统，Windows、Linux 或 OS X，它会告诉你每个目录中你正在使用哪些磁盘。更具体地说，它会给你这些非常酷的可视化效果。
So, for example, you could say, oh, your programming directory is like 70% of your hard drive. But then you can drill down and it'll sort everything for you. So you can say, like, what in my programming directory is so big? And then you see, oh, my programming slash art directory is huge. It has all these art assets. And then drill down there and say, oh,, you know half these art assets are for things I don't use anymore Let me put these like let me like zip these and put them on a DVD so I don't have to keep them on my
所以，例如，你可以说，哦，你的编程目录占了你硬盘的 70%。但然后你可以深入挖掘，它会为你整理一切。所以你可以说，我的编程目录里有什么这么大？然后你看到，哦，我的编程/艺术目录太大了。它有所有这些艺术资产。然后深入挖掘那里说，哦，你知道这些艺术资产有一半是我不再使用的东西，让我把这些压缩起来放在 DVD 上，这样我就不必把它们留在我的
hard drive, right so um so for Windows it's called winder stat and If you take a look at that it gives you it's pretty cool when you run it it has like these little Pac-man's So it starts off with just one Pac-man, and it has like C colon, right? Or maybe it has a Pac-Man for every hard drive. But then it says, oh, C has these four directories in it. It has Windows, programming, whatever, you know, users, whatever it has. And it will create like four Pac-Mans that go and scan those directories. Next thing you know, there's like hundreds of these little Pac-Man symbols.
硬盘上了，对吧？所以，对于 Windows，它叫 WinDirStat，如果你看一下，它非常酷，当你运行它时，它有这些小吃豆人。所以它开始时只有一个吃豆人，它有 C 盘，对吧？或者也许它为每个硬盘都有一个吃豆人。但然后它说，哦，C 盘里有这四个目录。它有 Windows、编程、无论什么，你知道，用户，无论它有什么。它会创建四个吃豆人去扫描那些目录。接下来你知道，有数百个这些小吃豆人符号。
It's kind of cool. Recursively scanning your entire hard drive. So it does take a while to run initially, but then after that, the drilling down and exploration goes fairly quickly. Yeah, that's right. So the idea here is, you know, you kick this thing off, and this is true for all three of the programs. You kick it off, you come back like the next day or the morning, you know,
这很酷。递归扫描你的整个硬盘。所以它最初运行确实需要一段时间，但之后，深入挖掘和探索进行得相当快。是的，没错。所以这里的想法是，你知道，你启动这个东西，这对所有三个程序都是如此。你启动它，你第二天或早上回来，你知道，
and then it gives you all these cool visualizations. Then you go through and start deleting stuff. And it's smart about, you know, if I delete a folder, it goes back and refigures out all the percents and redoes the graph without spending a lot of time there. So WinDirStat. Yeah, WinDirStat. Look on the show notes because it's a little bit complicated.
然后它会给你所有这些酷炫的可视化效果。然后你浏览并开始删除东西。它很聪明，你知道，如果我删除一个文件夹，它会回去重新计算所有百分比并重做图表，而不需要花费太多时间。所以 WinDirStat。是的， WinDirStat。查看节目笔记，因为它有点复杂。
Yeah, yeah. It's all one word. It's kind of weird. But the show notes has a link. And that's Windows. Yeah, that's right. On Linux, it's Disk of weird but uh the show notes has a link so that's windows yeah that's right on linux it's a disk usage analyzer and there's no link for this because it comes built in with ubuntu but uh pretty sure if you run you know slackware or debian or any of these um you know
是的，是的。它是一个词。这有点奇怪。但节目笔记里有一个链接。那是 Windows。是的，没错。在 Linux 上，它是磁盘使用分析器，没有这个的链接，因为它内置在 Ubuntu 中，但我很确定如果你运行 Slackware 或 Debian 或任何这些发行版，你都会有某种类型的磁盘使用分析器变体。然后对于 OS X，我使用 Disk Inventory X。所以这个有点不同。它给你这种奇怪的四叉树，一切都被分成单元格。但可视化效果不如 WinDirStat 好，但它做的事情类似。太棒了。非常有用。非常有用。说到我在完成工作方面的效率和生产力，我本周的工具是一个游戏。免费游戏。不是开源的，但免费。Spelunky。
uh distributions that you'll have some type of disk usage analyzer variant on there. Then for OS X, I use Disk Inventory X. And so this one's a little bit different. It gives you this sort of weird quad tree kind of thing where everything's split into cells. But the visualization is not as good as Winderstat, but it does a similar thing. Awesome. Very useful. Very useful. So talking about how effective and productive I am at getting work done, my tool of this week is a game. Free game. Not open source, but free. Spelunky.
Spelunky 很有趣。我只玩了一点点，Jason 看到这个时非常兴奋，因为这将是我的东西。我想他比我更兴奋这个成为本周工具。这个游戏太棒了。所以他实际上玩这个玩得更多。
And Spelunky is interesting. And I've only played it a little bit, and Jason got so excited when he saw this that this was going to be my thing. I think he is more excited about this being a tool of the week than I am. This game is amazing. So he's actually playing this more.
所以想法是你是一个……因为说这个我们会惹上麻烦。印第安纳琼斯式的角色。是的。所以一个洞穴冒险 Spelunky 引用
So the idea is you are a... We're going to get in trouble for saying this. Indiana Jones-like character. Yeah. So a cave adventure Spelunky referencing
spelunking，进入洞穴的行为，我假设。这些书呆子真是太聪明了。是的。除非你在谈论城市探洞，
spelunking, the act of going down into caves, I assume. Such a clever play on words these nerds are. Yeah. Unless you're talking about urban spelunking,
也就是进入底特律和其他城市废弃地区的地方。好的。这些书呆子真是太聪明了，是的，除非你在谈论城市探洞，
which is going into places in Detroit and other urban abandoned areas. Okay. words these nerds are yeah unless you're talking about urban splunking which is going into like places in detroit and other like you know urban abandoned areas okay i didn't know about this phenomenon yeah that's pretty wild but but yeah regular splunking is what's going on here so your cave explorer explores randomly generated levels so the game randomly generates you a level and then you play through it trying to accomplish the goal of rescuing the princess i don't know the girl and some of them that's the goal the beginning ones i think so in the later ones i i maybe it can change but uh so even though there's the goal of getting through this randomly generated level you don't just play on forever they actually establish a meta game
也就是进入底特律和其他城市废弃地区的地方。好的，我不知道这个现象。是的，这很疯狂，但是的，常规探洞就是这里发生的事情，所以你的洞穴探险家探索随机生成的关卡，所以游戏随机为你生成一个关卡，然后你玩它，试图完成拯救公主的目标，我不知道，女孩，其中一些就是目标，我想最初的那些是，在后来的那些中，也许它可以改变，但所以即使有通过这个随机生成关卡的目标，你也不会永远玩下去，他们实际上建立了一个元游戏
outside of the individual level that you play and the goal there is that you can continue to accomplish things in each level, and then you can move on through this meta game. And it actually does have a conclusion, Jason informed me of, spoiler alert. Yeah, so Splunky's kind of fun. It's an evolution of NetHack and Rogue and all these games, and Diablo, in a sense,
在个人关卡之外，你玩这个，目标是你可以继续在每个关卡中完成事情，然后你可以通过这个元游戏继续前进。它确实有一个结论，Jason 告诉我的，剧透警告。是的，所以 Spelunky 很有趣。它是 NetHack 和 Rogue 以及所有这些游戏，以及 Diablo 的一种进化，在某种意义上，
which had randomly generated levels. But the cool thing that Splunky adds is this mechanic where you know it's really hard to go through the whole game without dying because you have one life and you only have what two or three hits i think it's two hits and then you die so imagine like mario but with one life right so it's very hard to make it all the way to like bowser's castle right in one shot so but what the game does to sort of keep you into it is it takes all the points that you've accumulated, you know, in your very short lifespan, and it puts it away. It puts it, like, in a vault.
它有随机生成的关卡。但 Spelunky 增加的酷点是这个机制，你知道，很难在不死亡的情况下通关整个游戏，因为你只有一条命，而且你只有两次或三次打击，我想是两次打击，然后你就死了，所以想象一下像马里奥，但只有一条命，对吧？所以很难一次性一直到达库巴城堡，对吧？所以，但游戏为了让你保持参与所做的是，它把你积累的所有分数，你知道，在你非常短暂的生命周期中，它把它存起来。它把它放在一个金库里。
And these points are accumulated, you know, every time you play. It's just cumulative. So eventually you get enough points where it says okay patrick you don't have to play level one anymore like we're gonna start you off at level two success yeah so it's like you have like the the the short-term game let's see how far i can get you know because if you're super amazing you could beat the game in one shot there's nothing stopping you from going right through all 16 levels but there's also this meta game of you know get as many points you can each time you play and then eventually you'll start off you know meeting the boss right away so definitely game check out free waste some time i think it's
这些分数是积累的，你知道，每次你玩的时候。它只是累积的。所以最终你得到了足够的分数，它说，好的 Patrick，你不需要再玩第一关了，我们要让你从第二关开始。成功。是的，所以就像你有短期游戏，让我们看看我能走多远，你知道，因为如果你超级厉害，你可以一次性通关，没有什么能阻止你直接通过所有 16 个关卡，但也有这个元游戏，你知道，每次玩都尽可能多地得分，然后最终你会开始直接遇到老板。所以绝对去看看这个免费游戏，浪费一些时间，我想它
only support on windows they're working on it looks like a game for xbox live yeah it looks like someone's made a mac port okay yeah i just googled splunky osx and uh there is a Mac port. I just googled Splunky OSX and there is a Mac port. I don't know if it works or not. Your mileage may vary. Disclaimer here. We have no idea. Maybe we could go to the standby of Run It in Wine on Linux.
只支持 Windows，他们正在努力，看起来像是一个 Xbox Live 游戏。是的，看起来有人制作了 Mac 移植版。好的，是的，我刚刚谷歌了 Spelunky OSX，有一个 Mac 移植版。我刚刚谷歌了 Spelunky OSX，有一个 Mac 移植版。我不知道它是否有效。你的结果可能会有所不同。这里有免责声明。我们不知道。也许我们可以使用在 Linux 上用 Wine 运行它的备用方案。
Hopefully that'll work for you. Wine's gotten really, really much better. Definitely check out SpelunkyWorld.com, and that'll be in the show notes as well. Yep. So I think the time has come, Jason. We are at the discussion of the programming language of the week, Dart.
希望这对你有用。Wine 已经变得非常非常好了。一定要去看看 SpelunkyWorld.com，这也会在节目笔记中。是的。所以我认为时间到了，Jason。我们到了讨论本周编程语言 Dart 的时候了。
Yes, Dart. If you Google Dart, you will not find the programming language. Oh, no. You'll actually have to Google Dartlang to get even the programming language. It just gives you an idea of how new it is and also how hard it is to get Google cred for the word Dart and steal it away. People wouldn't think of this before they named their languages. Yeah, yeah.
是的，Dart。如果你谷歌 Dart，你找不到这种编程语言。哦，不。你实际上必须谷歌 Dartlang 才能得到这种编程语言。这只是让你知道它有多新，以及为 Dart 这个词获得谷歌信任并将其夺走有多难。人们在命名他们的语言之前不会想到这一点。是的，是的。
Like the last Google language was Go, and you'd think they would have learned. Yeah. After Go, you'd think they would have learned, let's pick something that's not a common word. But they picked Dart. So I guess you left that kind of the bag. It's a Google language? That's right.
就像上一个谷歌语言是 Go，你会认为他们会学到教训。是的。在 Go 之后，你会认为他们会学到教训，让我们选择一些不是常用词的东西。但他们选择了 Dart。所以我猜你把那个东西从袋子里拿出来了。这是一种谷歌语言？没错。
That's right. So it's being worked at by Google engineers. And it has a sort of interesting genesis. So Dart is a, let's talk a little bit about darts a client uh browser based um it's meant to be run in a browser right okay similar to javascript so uh basically dart tries to kind of get around a lot of the drawbacks a lot of the weaknesses of javascript from an enterprise or a big iron javascript has weakness i know shocking i think we covered we did cover javascript so yes so listen to that episode yeah
没错。所以它是由谷歌工程师开发的。它有一个有趣的起源。所以 Dart 是一种，让我们谈谈 Dart 是一种客户端基于浏览器的，它旨在在浏览器中运行，对吧？好的，类似于 JavaScript，所以基本上 Dart 试图绕过 JavaScript 的许多缺点，从企业或大型机的角度来看，JavaScript 有弱点，我知道，令人震惊，我想我们涵盖了，我们确实涵盖了 JavaScript，所以是的，所以听听那一集。是的，
definitely go back and check that out and hopefully we'll be consistent but we're not we're not we're not checking ourselves so it's been a while it has been a while people have been born since we uh did the last show families have increased in size. It's like Agricola. This is like the next turn. I actually made that joke. My wife didn't find it funny. Oh, really? Yes, you have taken the family growth action. Nice.
一定要回去看看，希望我们会保持一致，但我们没有，我们没有在检查自己，所以已经有一段时间了，确实有一段时间了，自从我们做上一期节目以来，人们已经出生了，家庭规模已经增加了。这就像 Agricola。这就像下一回合。我实际上开了那个玩笑。我妻子觉得不好笑。哦，真的吗？是的，你已经采取了家庭增长行动。不错。
But yeah, so one of the biggest things about JavaScript is that you can get errors at runtime. It's not statically typed. And it doesn't have a lot of the things that many other languages like Java and C++, languages which have been used in huge applications, it doesn't have a lot of those features, which make it easy for collaborative development and things like that. So Google actually made a product called Google Web Toolkit or GWT for short. And Google Web Toolkit, the idea was you would write code in Java and then this Google Web Toolkit would turn all of your Java code into
但是的，所以关于 JavaScript 的最大事情之一是你在运行时可能会出错。它不是静态类型的。它没有许多其他语言（如 Java 和 C++，这些在大型应用程序中使用的语言）所具有的许多功能，它没有很多那些功能，这使得协作开发变得容易。所以谷歌实际上制作了一个名为 Google Web Toolkit 或简称 GWT 的产品。而 Google Web Toolkit 的想法是，你用 Java 编写代码，然后这个 Google Web Toolkit 会把你所有的 Java 代码变成
JavaScript. And this worked out pretty well but it it has some major issues, and we won't really get into that too much detail. But basically, it doesn't really serve the full use case, and it doesn't have a lot of traction. So Dart is an attempt to sort of create a brand new language that can give you kind of like the flexibility and the rapid prototyping that you need to make things quick and make web apps quick. Web developers are all about keeping up to date with the latest UI, making something sleek, making it look really nice, making it interact with the HTML and make it very interactive. And so they don't want to be constrained with all the statically typing. But then on the other hand, you want to write huge programs that run in the browser.
JavaScript。这效果很好，但它有一些主要问题，我们不会深入探讨太多细节。但基本上，它并没有真正服务于完整的用例，而且它没有太大的吸引力。所以 Dart 是一种尝试，旨在创造一种全新的语言，可以给你那种灵活性和快速原型设计，你需要快速制作东西并快速制作 Web 应用程序。Web 开发人员都致力于跟上最新的 UI，制作一些时尚的东西，让它看起来非常好，让它与 HTML 交互并使其非常具有交互性。所以他们不想被所有的静态类型所束缚。但另一方面，你想编写在浏览器中运行的大型程序。
And so Dart is a way to sort of balance both of these. This is an interesting point that when you make a language, everybody thinks they have the right way to make a language, but it's very, very difficult to do everything well. And so oftentimes you make sacrifices by saying, this is what we're going to do well. And if you don't like that then find another tool write your own yeah and so i guess this is google stepping up to play and saying
所以 Dart 是一种平衡这两者的方法。这是一个有趣的观点，当你制作一种语言时，每个人都认为他们有正确的方法来制作语言，但要做好每一件事是非常非常困难的。所以通常你会通过说“这是我们要做好的一件事”来做出牺牲。如果你不喜欢那样，那就找另一个工具，自己写一个。是的，所以我猜这是谷歌站出来说
there were some things they didn't like about javascript and so they're going to write their own yep yeah and so google web toolkit was um just too much of a departure from the things that made javascript great and uh so dart is attempt to sort of bring those closer together. So as we mentioned, it runs in the browser. Right now, there's only a – so let's talk a little bit about virtual machines, right? Okay. Yeah, we covered that before. But yeah, let's do a refresher. Yeah, yeah. So JavaScript runs on the V8 virtual machine, which runs inside of a browser. I thought that runs in a car.
他们不喜欢 JavaScript 的一些地方，所以他们要写自己的。是的，是的，所以 Google Web Toolkit 与使 JavaScript 伟大的东西相去甚远，所以 Dart 是试图将它们拉得更近的尝试。正如我们提到的，它在浏览器中运行。现在，只有一个——所以让我们谈谈虚拟机，对吧？好的。是的，我们之前涵盖过。但是的，让我们复习一下。是的，是的。所以 JavaScript 在 V8 虚拟机上运行，它在浏览器内运行。我以为那是在汽车里运行。
Oh, sorry, different V8. Oh, I see. I knew that. It runs in an autonomous car. Ooh. So Dart can also run in the browser using its own virtual machine called Dartium, I think, or Dart VM, something like
哦，抱歉，不同的 V8。哦，我明白了。我知道了。它在自动驾驶汽车中运行。哦。所以 Dart 也可以使用它自己的名为 Dartium 或 Dart VM 的虚拟机在浏览器中运行，我想，或者类似
that. But now, you know, right now Dart VM only exists in Chrome. Hasn't been ported over. Which is made by Google. Right. Surprise! Yeah. Dee-dee-dee-ding.
那样。但现在，你知道，目前 Dart VM 只存在于 Chrome 中。还没有被移植过来。这是由谷歌制造的。对。惊喜！叮叮叮。
So it's not, you know, there's no Dart VM for Firefox or Internet Explorer or any of those. So you might think, oh, if I write my code in Dart, no one else who uses, you know, no one outside of Chrome can use it. That's not true. They wrote a compiler called Frog. And so what Frog does is it takes your dart code and turns
所以它不是，你知道，没有适用于 Firefox 或 Internet Explorer 或任何这些浏览器的 Dart VM。所以你可能会想，哦，如果我用 Dart 编写代码，任何使用 Chrome 以外浏览器的人都无法使用它。那不是真的。他们编写了一个名为 Frog 的编译器。所以 Frog 所做的是它获取你的 Dart 代码并将其变成
it into javascript so you could think of frog is to dart what the google web toolkit is to java so it's sort of a way to translate your code into javascript okay but at the same time if you don't want to use frog or you uh or if you're using dart you can actually detect the person's browser and say oh this guy's running chrome we can give him native dart code or this person's running internet explorer we'll use frog and give them javascript so so javascript we talked about this before has the name java in it but the similarities to java are so what about dart how is it similar to java then yeah yeah so dart and java are extremely similar so they're both uh class-based they both have classes interfaces this whole thing they have inheritance and i i believe we covered java right yeah yeah
JavaScript，所以你可以认为 Frog 对 Dart 就像 Google Web Toolkit 对 Java 一样，所以这是一种将你的代码翻译成 JavaScript 的方法。好的，但同时，如果你不想使用 Frog，或者如果你正在使用 Dart，你实际上可以检测人的浏览器并说，哦，这家伙正在运行 Chrome，我们可以给他原生 Dart 代码，或者这个人正在运行 Internet Explorer，我们将使用 Frog 并给他们 JavaScript。所以 JavaScript 我们之前谈过，名字里有 Java，但与 Java 的相似之处是，那么 Dart 呢？它与 Java 有什么相似之处？是的，是的，所以 Dart 和 Java 非常相似，所以它们都是基于类的，它们都有接口，整个东西，它们有继承，而且我相信我们涵盖了 Java，对吧？是的，是的，
we definitely covered java in a previous episode so uh definitely go back to that one but almost everything in Java as far as like the architecture the language and the semantics you'll also find in Dart. One nice thing about Dart is that it also sort of gives you some of the features of JavaScript if you want. So for example in Dart you can say int x equals three and now x has that 3 in it. If you later say x equals Patrick, it'll say an error. It'll say x is an int, and you tried to set it to Patrick, that's not going to fly. And so these are the kind of things that you want as a developer. You want it to give you an error up front.
我们肯定在之前的一集中涵盖了 Java，所以一定要回去看那一集，但 Java 中几乎所有关于架构、语言和语义的东西，你也会在 Dart 中找到。Dart 的一个好处是，如果你愿意，它也给你一些 JavaScript 的功能。例如，在 Dart 中，你可以说 int x = 3，现在 x 里有那个 3。如果你后来说 x = Patrick，它会报错。它会说 x 是一个 int，而你试图把它设置为 Patrick，那是不行的。所以这些是你作为开发人员想要的东西。你想要它预先给你一个错误。
You don't want to have to deploy this code, and then your customers run it, and then at runtime, they get some weird error because you tried to add Patrick and 10. You know, and at runtime, everything blows up after you've deployed it. Right. So Dart has that advantage of you can specify the type. You can say, look, this is a number and it'll always be a number. And if it's ever, you know, if ever something comes in that's a string and i set the number to a string just tell me right away that something don't let it bad it's happening yeah
你不想部署这段代码，然后你的客户运行它，然后在运行时，他们得到一些奇怪的错误，因为你试图添加 Patrick 和 10。你知道，在运行时，在你部署它之后，一切都崩溃了。对。所以 Dart 有这个优势，你可以指定类型。你可以说，看，这是一个数字，它永远是一个数字。如果有什么东西进来是一个字符串，而我把数字设置为字符串，就立刻告诉我，别让它发生。是的，
don't let this compile so um but it also you can use var so if you say var x equals three then you're telling dart i want x to be anything so so you can turn it off you can turn off the static typing yep and so this lets you be very flexible. So if you really want to hack something up quickly and you want to get out the door, or if you want to be flexible, maybe there really is a variable that could be anything and you want to be able to support that. Maybe some kind of user generated content or something like that. So Dart will handle that as well. Very nice. Interesting. Okay. So another cool feature of Dart that JavaScript does not have is multi-threading. And Dart actually has two kinds
别让它编译。所以，但你也可以使用 var，所以如果你说 var x = 3，那么你是在告诉 Dart 我想让 x 成为任何东西。所以你可以关闭它，你可以关闭静态类型。是的，所以这让你非常灵活。所以如果你真的想快速破解一些东西，你想快速完成，或者如果你想灵活，也许真的有一个变量可以是任何东西，你想能够支持它。也许是某种用户生成的内容之类的。所以 Dart 也会处理这个问题。非常好。有趣。好的。所以 Dart 的另一个酷功能是 JavaScript 没有的，那就是多线程。而 Dart 实际上有两种
of multi-threading. Because one wasn't enough. Yeah, that's right. If you'll notice, the big thing about Dart, and maybe we'll talk about this later in the strengths, is that Dart seems to try to do everything. It has statically typed, but it can do dynamically typed and it has many different types of multi-threading and it has actually dart has all of the java containers in it which is something that's really useful so yeah in the case of javascript right everything is a map so everything is if you want to say like you know day equals three or if you want to do you know day equals monday if you want to have some kind of enum everything has to be structured in a map but in the case of dart you can have lists you can have sets you could have maps all the things that you're used to in java um someone's gone in and
多线程。因为一种是不够的。是的，没错。如果你注意到，Dart 的大事情，也许我们稍后会在优势中谈到这一点，那就是 Dart 似乎试图做所有事情。它有静态类型，但它可以做动态类型，它有许多不同类型的多线程，而且实际上 Dart 拥有所有的 Java 容器，这是非常有用的东西。所以是的，在 JavaScript 的情况下，对吧，一切都是映射，所以一切都是，如果你想说，你知道，day = 3，或者如果你想做，你知道，day = Monday，如果你想有某种枚举，一切都必须结构化在一个映射中，但在 Dart 的情况下，你可以有列表，你可以有集合，你可以有映射，所有你在 Java 中习惯的东西，有人进去了，
written and those things in dart so it really comes batteries included as we talked about earlier so we like that phrase yeah yeah it's probably my favorite phrase of the show. Oh, just of the show. Okay. Yeah, or real life, yeah. Oh, you use that all the time. Yeah, pretty much. Nice.
写了那些东西在 Dart 中，所以它确实像我们之前谈到的那样“电池包含在内”。所以我们喜欢那个短语。是的，是的，这可能是我最喜欢的节目短语。哦，只是节目的。好的。是的，或者现实生活，是的。哦，你一直都在用那个。是的，差不多。不错。
Yeah, family growth option, batteries included. That's pretty much, that's my whole vocabulary. Oh, wow. Okay. I think we're just going to move on. So you were talking about multi-threading. Yeah, yeah. So Dart has coroutines, and it also has full multi-threading. Yeah, yeah. So Dart has coroutines and it also has full multi-threading.
是的，家庭增长选项，电池包含在内。这差不多就是我的全部词汇量。哦，哇。好的。我想我们要继续了。所以你在谈论多线程。是的，是的。所以 Dart 有协程，它也有完全的多线程。是的，是的。所以 Dart 有协程，它也有完全的多线程。
So have we talked about this before? We might have at some level, but we can go over it again. Maybe, how about I'll go over coroutines and you go over like multi-processing. Okay. All right. So coroutines are having multiple threads in a single process. So you might say to yourself, like, why would I want to do this, right? And the answer is, let's say you're waiting for someone to type a key on the keyboard,
所以我们之前谈过这个吗？我们可能在某种程度上谈过，但我们可以再过一遍。也许，我来过一遍协程，你来过一遍多处理。好的。好的。所以协程是在单个进程中拥有多个线程。所以你可能会对自己说，为什么我想这样做，对吧？答案是，假设你在等待某人敲击键盘上的键，
but at the same time, you were, you know, constantly updating your GUI. Maybe there's some like graphic animation going on in the background, but at the same time, you want someone to be able to type in or you want someone to click a button to stop the animation. So you need to be able to do both of these things at the same time. You don't want to have just one loop that says, you know, run a little bit of the animation and then check to see if Patrick pressed the key. And then run a little bit and go back and forth because this makes the code really confusing. What you really want is to have two different things running at the same time. One that's waiting for an input and the other that's running the animation. So you could do
但同时，你，你知道，不断更新你的 GUI。也许后台有一些图形动画正在进行，但同时，你希望某人能够输入，或者你希望某人点击一个按钮来停止动画。所以你需要能够同时做这两件事。你不想只有一个循环说，你知道，运行一点动画，然后检查 Patrick 是否按了键。然后运行一点，来回切换，因为这让代码非常混乱。你真正想要的是同时运行两件不同的事情。一个在等待输入，另一个在运行动画。所以你可以做
this in multi-processing where you have, you know, two different threads on your operating system that are both doing different things. But this causes a lot of overhead. Anytime you create another process, you have to go to the operating system and say, hey operating system I need another space to run some code and it has to go and fetch that for you and that's a little time-consuming. Also as we mentioned Dart can be compiled to JavaScript and JavaScript doesn't support multiprocessing. So, you know, there's no way to do that in JavaScript. So Dart has this idea of what's called what Dart calls a light isolate. And this allows you to do coroutines where you have many different threads, but they're all
这个在多处理中，你有，你知道，操作系统上的两个不同线程，它们都在做不同的事情。但这会导致很多开销。每当你创建另一个进程时，你必须去操作系统说，嘿操作系统，我需要另一个空间来运行一些代码，它必须去为你获取那个，这有点耗时。此外，正如我们提到的，Dart 可以编译成 JavaScript，而 JavaScript 不支持多处理。所以，你知道，在 JavaScript 中没有办法做到这一点。所以 Dart 有这个想法，叫做 Dart 称之为轻量级隔离。这允许你做协程，你有许多不同的线程，但它们都在
sharing a slice of the same process. So the process, basically, the process will do sort of what I was describing earlier, where it'll play a little bit of animation and then listen for a keystroke. But from a code perspective, you're writing code as if you have two things going at the same time. And the multi-threaded is simulated. So this is different than multi-processing, which... Yeah, so multi-processing, you know, Jason talked about threads sharing a process. And the process is kind of what the operating system deals in. And the operating system schedules processes for the processors to run. And there's overhead there such as, like, things that include, like, the stack.
共享同一个进程的一片空间。所以进程，基本上，进程会做我刚才描述的那种事情，它会播放一点动画，然后监听按键。但从代码的角度来看，你编写代码就像你有两件事同时进行一样。而多线程是模拟的。所以这与多处理不同，后者……是的，所以多处理，你知道，Jason 谈到了线程共享一个进程。而进程是操作系统处理的东西。操作系统调度进程供处理器运行。并且那里有开销，例如，包括堆栈的东西。
And when you make a thread inside a process, you kind of have to emulate that or eliminate it. And there's all sorts of ways of handling that based on you know what you're trying to accomplish but multi-processing in theory allows you if you have a whole process and you have multiple processors the operating system can schedule one process to run on one and one process to run on the other and give yourself true multiple things running at the same time versus the cpu just slicing very finely alternating between two different threads so as a programmer if the things you're doing aren't particularly intensive, like, you know, draw some animation, you know, check the keyboard, draw some animation, check the keyboard.
当你在一个进程内创建一个线程时，你必须模拟它或消除它。并且有各种各样的方法来处理这个问题，基于你知道你试图完成什么，但多处理在理论上允许你，如果你有一个完整的进程，并且你有多个处理器，操作系统可以调度一个进程在一个处理器上运行，另一个进程在另一个处理器上运行，并给自己真正同时运行的多件事，而不是 CPU 非常精细地在两个不同线程之间交替。所以作为程序员，如果你做的事情不是特别密集，比如，你知道，画一些动画，你知道，检查键盘，画一些动画，检查键盘。
If neither of those turn out to be, you know, intensive, or in this case, checking the keyboard, most of the time you're just doing nothing, then you can share one process on one processor and it's not a big deal. But if you want to, you know, render the graphics and also compute a path for some entity, if you're doing like, you know, game programming and you want to you know render the graphics and also compute a path for some entity if you're doing like you know game programming and you want to have ai those two things are very meaty uh intensive things and if you put them in a two threads inside of a single process makes it harder for the operating system to know what to do if you put them in two separate processes the operating system can say oh i'll put one on one processor and one on the other and then they
如果这两者都不是，你知道，密集的，或者在这种情况下，检查键盘，大多数时候你只是什么都不做，那么你可以在一个处理器上共享一个进程，这没什么大不了的。但如果你想，你知道，渲染图形并计算某个实体的路径，如果你在做，你知道，游戏编程，你想，你知道，渲染图形并计算某个实体的路径，如果你在做，你知道，游戏编程，你想拥有 AI，这两件事是非常繁重的、密集的任务，如果你把它们放在单个进程内的两个线程中，操作系统就很难知道该做什么。如果你把它们放在两个单独的进程中，操作系统可以说，哦，我会把一个放在一个处理器上，另一个放在另一个处理器上，然后它们
can run at the same time and in theory make your stuff go twice as fast. There's lots of issues with that simplification, but that's what it means at a low level. But sometimes you don't need that. And there's overhead that's incurred from the processor standpoint, switching the process, having all this extra information that the operating system stores about it, and moving those in and out of the processor, depending on what's running, is something that you want to avoid if you don't need it. But sometimes you need it, and it's worth it
可以同时运行，理论上让你的东西运行速度提高一倍。那个简化有很多问题，但这就是它在低层面的意思。但有时你不需要那个。并且从处理器的角度来看，切换进程会产生开销，操作系统存储关于它的所有这些额外信息，并将它们移入和移出处理器，取决于正在运行什么，这是如果你不需要它就想避免的事情。但有时你需要它，它是值得的
if it means you can get scheduled on two different processors at the same time. Yeah, totally. So the only other thing I guess I can mention on that is that the heavy isolates, you don't share any data, which, as Patrick mentioned, because they're on two different they're two different processes so the so you have to basically pass messages from one isolate or from the main thread to the isolates versus the light isolates they can actually share data because they know that there have to be on the same process yeah exactly so and then oh
如果这意味着你可以同时在两个不同的处理器上被调度。是的，完全。所以我猜我能提到的关于那个的唯一其他事情是，重量级隔离，你不共享任何数据，正如 Patrick 提到的，因为它们在两个不同的，它们是两个不同的进程，所以你基本上必须从一个隔离或从主线程向隔离发送消息，而轻量级隔离它们实际上可以共享数据，因为它们知道它们必须在同一个进程上。是的，完全。然后哦
man we could do a whole whole episode about even that's not language focused but about the differences and all the different ways that cpus handle multi-threading and multi-processing and different languages and that's something that today is becoming more uh applicable than ever before because it's processors stop getting faster and start getting more cores this is something that we have to start worrying about how do we schedule efficiently 32 cores to do something on the on the computer and it's not always straightforward most of the time is yeah definitely we should do if we do go as a language we should do like a whole thing yeah yeah definitely so so what are the what are the strengths that dart we said it tries to do a lot of things so so what are those strengths that really shines in yeah so i think one of the um
天哪，我们可以做一整集关于那个，即使不是语言重点，而是关于 CPU 处理多线程和多处理的所有不同方式以及不同语言，这是今天变得比以往任何时候都更适用的东西，因为处理器停止变得更快并开始拥有更多核心，这是我们必须开始担心的事情，我们如何有效地调度 32 个核心来在计算机上做某事，而且这并不总是直接的，大多数时候是。是的，绝对地，如果我们确实把 Go 作为一种语言，我们应该做一整套。是的，是的，绝对地。所以，Dart 的优势是什么？我们说它试图做很多事情，所以那些真正闪光的优势是什么？是的，所以我认为其中一个……
you know biggest strengths of dart is that it gives it gives you the sort of um what's a good way of describing it it gives you the sort of structure that you're used to as a like that people have been developing with for years you know it's it's it's not very often that you see you know a 200,000 line JavaScript program and many JavaScript developers will say that's a good thing it's because we can get it done in 20 lines or something but the reality is you know if you have 30 people working on a project you really want things to be encapsulated maybe that's the best word I'm really looking for. So you want to be able to say, look this is my
你知道，Dart 最大的优势是它给你那种，嗯，描述它的好方法是什么？它给你那种你作为，你知道，人们多年来一直在开发的那种结构。你知道，你很少看到，你知道，20 万行的 JavaScript 程序，许多 JavaScript 开发人员会说这是一件好事，这是因为我们可以在 20 行左右完成它，但现实是，你知道，如果你有 30 个人在一个项目上工作，你真的希望事情被封装，也许这是我真正寻找的最好的词。所以你希望能够说，看，这是我的
graphics handler class for my part of this game and the way you interact with me is you can say like add sprite, remove sprite. So I'm going to give you an interface with some functions and you can code to this interface and then but internally you know I'm going to be doing all the handling of the drawing the pixels and things like that I'm just going to expose sort of an API that's sort of that's the way a lot of these big languages work like C++ you have the header file and you can give somebody the header file without the source file and they should be able to interact with your code even though they don't know what's happening under the hood. In the case of Java, you know, they typically use Java docs, right? So you can see a Java doc with
游戏这一部分的图形处理类，你与我交互的方式是你可以说，比如添加精灵，移除精灵。所以我将给你一个带有某些功能的接口，你可以针对这个接口进行编码，然后但在内部，你知道，我将处理绘制像素等所有事情，我只是要公开某种 API，这就像许多这些大型语言工作的方式，比如 C++，你有头文件，你可以给某人头文件而没有源文件，他们应该能够与你的代码交互，即使他们不知道引擎盖下发生了什么。在 Java 的情况下，你知道，他们通常使用 Java docs，对吧？所以你可以看到一个 Java doc，带有
the API and you can code to this API, even if you don't know what the code is doing, because it's very structured. You know, in the case of JavaScript, this doesn't really exist, right? It's JavaScript, everything is an object. And it's very hard. You can define an API, but you're doing a lot of the heavy lifting yourself. Dart sort of takes a step back and says, let's give us more of a Java or C++ feel to browser-based, to client-side browser computing. And that's something that especially if you go to working with large teams of people, it's something that is really beneficial. It also seems nice that it has the option for the static typing or the dynamic typing. So if you really want dynamic typing and you're in Dart, great,
API，你可以针对这个API进行编码，即使你不知道代码在做什么，因为它非常结构化。你知道，在JavaScript的情况下，这并不真正存在，对吧？它是JavaScript，一切都是对象。这非常困难。你可以定义一个API，但你需要自己做很多繁重的工作。Dart退后了一步，说，让我们为基于浏览器的客户端浏览器计算提供一种更像Java或C++的感觉。这尤其在与大型团队合作时非常有益。它似乎也很好，因为它提供了静态类型或动态类型的选择。所以如果你真的想要动态类型，并且你在使用Dart，那太棒了，
use it. But if you have that static typing to enable those compile time checks and make sure you didn't just try to put a string in an integer or vice versa, or try to add three to a string, which doesn't make a lot of sense or is ambiguous, that it's really nice to be able to have that because it enables, again, if Jason wrote one piece of line of code and I wrote another, and I thought he was using a string,
那就使用它。但如果你有静态类型来启用那些编译时检查，并确保你没有试图把一个字符串放进一个整数里，反之亦然，或者试图把三加到一个字符串上（这没什么意义或模棱两可），那么能够拥有这些检查真的很好，因为它再次启用了——如果Jason写了一行代码，而我写了另一行，而我以为他在使用字符串，
in reality, he was using an integer, then, you know, it could be a problem. And so it's nice to be able to kind of have those enforcements and checks there if you want them. Yeah, I mean, just to put an example, I mean, let's say, you know know I was writing this graphics engine and Patrick was using it as part of his game. You know in the case of JavaScript I just create a set of functions but I don't really say oh you have to pass in two
实际上他在使用一个整数，那么，你知道，这可能会成为一个问题。所以如果需要的话，能够有这些强制执行和检查是很好的。是的，我的意思是，举个例子，假设我正在编写这个图形引擎，而Patrick正在将其作为他游戏的一部分使用。你知道，在JavaScript的情况下，我只是创建了一组函数，但我并没有真正说，哦，你必须传入两个
integers and a string or something like that. And in fact in JavaScript I believe you can pass the wrong number of arguments and it'll just put in none for the other ones So if I go in and change my API Patrick might not know He definitely won't know at compile time because there's no compiler JavaScript's completely interpreted, right? But even at runtime it could be just really like the code can just do really strange things that you're not sure of if someone You know changes an implementation of something but with dart it sort of allows you to you know
整数和一个字符串之类的东西。事实上，在JavaScript中，我相信你可以传入错误数量的参数，它只会为其他参数填入none。所以如果我进去修改了我的API，Patrick可能不会知道。他肯定不会在编译时知道，因为没有编译器，JavaScript是完全解释执行的，对吧？但即使在运行时，代码也可能做一些非常奇怪的事情，如果你不确定的话，如果有人修改了某样东西的实现，但有了Dart，它某种程度上允许你，你知道，
to to create these modules and so it allows two people to sort of work together in parallel without having to constantly stay in sync so we already talked about a little but some of the weaknesses is that the frog compiler isn't an efficient generator of javascript code doesn't you could do better by hand you know right now javascript now tends to be with any transition tends to be the first thing that happens is people go i could write this better myself and it's like well yeah but that's not the point yeah i think at some point someone was telling me i think when i was in like middle school or something like oh we could do this so much better in assembly you know
创建这些模块，因此它允许两个人并行工作，而不必不断地保持同步。所以我们已经讨论了一点，但它的一些弱点是Frog编译器不是一个高效的JavaScript代码生成器，你手动编写可能会更好。你知道，现在JavaScript在任何过渡时期，人们首先想到的往往是“我自己能写得更好”，这确实没错，但重点不在这里。是的，我想在某个时候有人告诉我，我想是在我上初中还是什么时候，哦，我们用汇编语言能做得好得多，你知道，
i mean it's always true but at the end it comes down to are you going to pay the price in your you know how much time you have to invest or in how fast it's going to run so we always try to give some uses of dart and i think that's especially difficult because it's pretty early on i mean darts darts relatively new what a year less than a year now yeah i don't even know and so um oh we failed to do a little bit of research that's okay and so it's still pretty experimental and you know nobody kind of really knows what google's intentions are per se with dart and where they're trying to go with it and so um people are playing around and then we'll see you know what kind of happens but you know maybe we do this this is a little bit earlier in the life cycle of a language than we've done before
我的意思是，这总是真的，但最终归结为你是否愿意付出代价，你知道，你必须投入多少时间，或者它运行得有多快。所以我们总是尝试给出一些Dart的用途，我认为这尤其困难，因为它还处于早期阶段。我的意思是，Dart相对较新，一年？不到一年吧？是的，我甚至不知道。所以，哦，我们没做多少研究，没关系。所以它仍然相当实验性，你知道，没有人真正知道谷歌对Dart的意图是什么，以及他们想用它去向何方。所以人们正在尝试，然后我们会看到会发生什么，但也许我们这样做，这在语言生命周期中比我们以前做的要早一点，
but it's something interesting but uh jason you did find one kind of cool use, one app that was using Dart. Yeah, it looks like some guys got together and made this thing called Dartendo. Dartendo. Yeah, which we'll give a link on the show notes. But it's dartendo.appspot.com. And it looks like it's a complete Nintendo emulator written in Dart. Wait, so a Nintendo emulator in my browser? Yeah, it's a complete Nintendo emulator written in Dart. Wait, so a Nintendo emulator in my browser?
但这很有趣。但是，Jason，你确实发现了一个很酷的用途，一个正在使用Dart的应用程序。是的，看起来有些人聚在一起做了这个叫Dartendo的东西。Dartendo。是的，我们会在节目笔记中提供链接。它是dartendo.appspot.com。看起来它是一个用Dart编写的完整任天堂模拟器。等等，所以是一个在浏览器里的任天堂模拟器？是的，它是一个用Dart编写的完整任天堂模拟器。等等，所以是一个在浏览器里的任天堂模拟器？
Yeah, it's kind of wild, and these guys made a drill TV graphic around it to make it look like it's, make it feel more homely. Retro. Yeah. But yeah, it completely runs the NES, and it looks like you can load drag-and-drop ROMs into it and stuff like that. Oh, so you have to upload your own that you've legally obtained by soldering memory readers onto your Nintendo cartridges. That's right. And getting the code from.
是的，这有点疯狂，这些人还在它周围做了一个电视图形，让它看起来更亲切。复古。是的。但它确实完全运行了NES，看起来你可以把ROM拖放到里面，诸如此类。哦，所以你必须上传你自己通过将内存读取器焊接到任天堂卡带上而合法获得的ROM。没错。并从中获取代码。
Yes, I have many such cartridges that I've done this to. Yeah, so for everybody out there who has desoldered their Nintendo cartridges that they purchased with their hard-earned money and put the ROMs on their on their computer they could do that otherwise it runs a little Nintendo test suite which that by itself is kind of interesting you can see how the Nintendo self test so this is a guy audio video control yeah yeah it seems to have the whole shebang interesting all right well people can check that out yeah it Yeah, it's actually open source, and it looks like it's a pretty hefty amount of Dart code. Okay. So it's always good to be able to look at an application written in a language and kind of get a feel for how people do things
是的，我有许多这样的卡带，我已经这样做了。是的，所以对于所有那些拆焊了他们用辛苦赚来的钱购买的任天堂卡带并将ROM放到电脑上的人来说，他们可以这样做。否则，它会运行一个小型的任天堂测试套件，这本身就很有趣，你可以看到任天堂的自检是如何进行的，所以这是一个音频视频控制，是的，它似乎拥有所有功能。有趣。好吧，人们可以去看看。是的，它实际上是开源的，看起来它有相当多的Dart代码。好的。所以能够查看用某种语言编写的应用程序并了解人们是如何做事的总是好的，
or what's being done. So that's definitely useful. Yeah, yeah, for sure. For sure. All right, man. Well, you got anything else? It's been a long time, but it feels good to be back in the, not in the driver's seat, in the podcasting seat. Yeah, it does. Yeah, it feels good to be doing this again. We appreciate all the comments. You know, a lot of people were kind of saying, hey, you know, when's the next episode? We were missed. It's nice to be missed. doing this we're definitely going to keep it going now that uh christmas season has ended and we're both back in uh uh back in our hometown or not in our hometown but uh back to our place of residence yeah our landing pad i don't know what the right word is but now that we're not traveling all over the place so uh it's kind of nice to uh to to be back doing this awesome well until next time
或者正在做什么。所以这绝对是有用的。是的，当然。当然。好吧，伙计。你还有什么别的吗？已经很久了，但回到——不是驾驶座，而是播客座位，感觉真好。是的，确实。是的，再次做这件事感觉很好。我们感谢所有的评论。你知道，很多人都在说，嘿，下一集什么时候出？我们被想念了。被想念的感觉真好。我们肯定会继续做下去，现在圣诞假期已经结束，我们都回到了我们的家乡，或者不是家乡，而是回到了我们的居住地。是的，我们的着陆点，我不知道正确的词是什么，但既然我们不用到处奔波，所以回到这里做这件事感觉真好。太棒了，那么下次见。
yeah have fun hacking with your Raspberry Pi or Arduino or whatever. If you can manage to buy one. Yeah, yeah, if you can get on the waiting list quick enough. So, all right, see you next time. See you later. The intro music is Axo by Binar Pilot. Programming Throwdown is distributed under a Creative Commons Attribution Sharealike 2.0 license. You're free to share copy distribute transmit the work to
是的，玩得开心，用你的树莓派或Arduino或任何东西进行黑客攻击。如果你能设法买到一个的话。是的，是的，如果你能足够快地进入等待名单的话。那么，好吧，下次见。再见。片头音乐是Binar Pilot的Axo。Programming Throwdown是在知识共享署名-相同方式共享2.0许可下分发的。你可以自由分享、复制、分发、传播该作品，以
remix adapt the work but you must provide attribution to Patrick and I and share alike in kind There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
进行重混、改编，但你必须注明我和Patrick的署名，并以相同方式共享。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。